the minimalists are once again going on
tour this is our tenth tour in ten years
it is called the les Coast tour will be
hitting eight cities across the west
coast of the United States and Canada
for more details head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour we'll see
you soon
animists hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist thanks for joining us
today we're gonna talk about 80-hour
workweeks we're gonna talk about packed
schedules we're gonna talk about endless
meetings we're gonna talk about Ryan's
overflowing inbox we're gonna talk about
unrealistic deadlines and we're gonna
talk about bringing our work home with
us all of the fun things that modern
life has presented to us and we're gonna
do all this well today's guest Jason
freed is here he is the author of this
book I'm gonna hold it up it is called
it doesn't have to be crazy it works so
if you're watching this on youtube you
can you can see the cover here I just
got this less than two days ago Jason
and I'm already more than halfway
through it and I've got to tell you we
are we are kindred spirits my friend we
we have many of the same values but also
many of the same ideas I love what
you've done with a lot of the principles
in here you sort of you've distilled
down well I guess 20 years you started
Basecamp 20 years ago years Wow and so
you've learned a lot in those 20 years
and and a lot of those lessons have made
it in here and I gotta tell you like
there are some things that Ryan and I
have even written about like having no
goals that is a that is part of my ethos
is not having goals and you don't have
go and people when I tell people I don't
have goals they look like I'm crazy or
lazy or stupid how do you know if you're
winning yeah and so there are just a lot
of principles and we'll will dive into
the book there's a lot I want to talk to
you about but this is a listener driven
show so I figured we would start with
some questions today about being too
busy our first question is from Amanda
in Nashville how you
suggest someone goes about balancing
their financial stability and their
mental stability recently I moved to a
new city and I've been struggling with
being able to keep afloat but I
understand that there's no sense in
spending all of your hours working to
make a dollar if you're going to be
miserable I guess that's the struggle
that I've been having recently as some
people say it's really hard some people
say it's really easy just got to go to
work do what you need to do and make it
happen but I feel like it's a little
more complicated than that
so Jason you write about this in the
book actually there is a certain
expectation I think a lot of it is sort
of internal with the 80-hour workweeks
but also there are bosses and bosses
bosses who sort of set a precedent there
the first one in and the last one out
and I that was actually me when I was a
a middle manager back in the corporate
world I managed 150 retail stores and I
would I made sure that I was the first
person in either was either me or my
boss so he set the precedent and then I
was the last one I was turned the lights
out at at 8 p.m. after everyone left but
I was busy I don't I wasn't necessarily
efficient or I was productive as you
write in the book yeah people are
obsessed with productivity yeah I don't
know like I think part of this whole
thing is is that we set expectations for
ourselves they're kind of impossible to
meet and bosses sometimes set
expectations that are impossible to meet
deadlines they're impossible to meet
growth targets that are impossible to
meet all sorts of targets all sorts of
expectations and we've really tried to
not do any of that basically we just
kind of say let's try to do the best
work we can like that's it cuz we should
be doing that anyway like I don't need
to set a target to do the best work I
can I should do the best work I can
that's what I want to do and that's all
I expected myself and anybody's do the
best work we can and I think when you
know when it comes to hitting things or
or or or you know being busy sometimes
we feel like we're we have to be busy to
feel like we're we're doing something
worthwhile I think I gotta fill my time
you know you got to fill your time and
the truth is is like there's a lot of
things to do during the day but there's
not that
much work that probably really needs to
get done so we invent work to do and we
keep ourselves busy we bounce back and
forth between tasks and we're addicted
to and you wrote about this in the book
as well we're addicted to interruptions
and you had this equation in there where
it was like 1 times 60 it still equals 1
or 1 yeah one time 60 is an hour or or 2
times 30 is also an hour and in what
like 10 times 6 minutes at a time is
also an hour but there's three
completely different hours right because
if we're constantly interrupted we're
doing busy work but we're not actually
getting the meaningful work done we're
especially creative work I think it
needs you need uninterrupted stretches
of time to really get into something
right now
and so yeah I mean that's like the limit
of my math skills is that sort of
equation there but basically you know we
try to shoot for I think people to try
to shoot for like doing one thing at a
time let's call it an hour just focus on
that for an hour
instead of bouncing between three or
four or five different things and the
problem is is that a lot of modern
technology prevents us from having
contiguous blocks of time we end up
bouncing new notification let's check
that out new email let's check that out
new zoom call let's check that out
whatever it might be and so we just end
up bouncing and bouncing and bouncing
and it's not that there's more work to
do it's that there's less time to do it
because our time our days have been
chunked into smaller and smaller and
smaller bits and then you can't really
get deep into something so you kind of
just like hit the surface and then you
bounce off of it you bounce on to
something else and you never get things
done just bouncing constantly I think
that's really a bad way to go about the
day yeah
now Ryan you I think you might have some
good advice here because she's really
talking about the financial side and the
mental side yeah and the problem with
this is like if she wants to work less
it's going to hurt her financially but
if she gets hurt financially now all of
a sudden it's going to have a an impact
on her on her sanity on the chaos on the
the mental clarity on the psychological
clutter the the mental stress that she's
experiencing and so then it becomes a
strange sort of downward spiral and yeah
it's hard it's hard to get out of that
because I think we all have a certain
base level of
you know she just moved to Nashville
it's a new city for her and of course
she has to pay the bills but then there
are all these other sort of inputs that
are telling her well you have to make
money to do this you have to make money
to do that yeah I mean I always like go
to an extreme example and I think you
know if someone offered her a million
dollars to rob a bank she probably
wouldn't do that now what she's doing
right now is is you know not nearly as
you know morally wrong as robbing a bank
but it is wrong to an extent I mean in
her question she said it she's like I
know there's no point in the working 80
hours a week seven days a week just to
forsake my mental stability and I
totally agree and when someone is in
that situation they do have to they have
to have one or two choices they can
continue doing what they're doing and we
all know that you know inevitably it's
going to get to a brick wall
and I know for me when I was doing this
60 70 80 hour work weeks I got to a
point where I mean I almost just got up
and quit and went bankrupt and like
because I was so stressed out right now
she's at a point where she doesn't have
to she's not in this pressure cooker
situation yet and she has an opportunity
to kind of work her way out of it so
yeah I mean she should probably she can
either leave her job find something
different or she can go to her boss and
if she's really adding value to the
company Josh did this before we left our
corporate jobs he went to his boss and
he was like hey look I'm not gonna
answer my phone after a certain time and
I'm not gonna get on my computer before
a certain time now the only reason Josh
could say that is because he added an
it's just an enormous amount of value to
the company so he had leverage to kind
of set his his some boundaries up so you
know maybe she can set up some
boundaries
if she can't set those boundaries up
yeah I agree um you don't want to
forsake your mental health just for a
seven-day work week just for the money
cuz again there are there are many ways
that you can make lots of money but
there are opportunity costs and
unfortunately you know your stress
levels your mental stability is is one
of those opportunity costs so she's got
she's got to find a way that is
kind of where I'm at with with my advice
to her yeah I mean Jason I assume you
you see this with with people in your
company if someone does feel stressed
out or they feel overworked I'm sure
it's happened before even with the the
company culture that you have especially
as you're trying new things out you're
working on new projects I think quite
often the bosses or managers or people
above where you are they want to be
sympathetic even though they're not
always they may not see and especially
the farther away they get from the work
you talk about that in the book they may
not even understand that you're stressed
out and feeling overwhelmed
yeah people put on a happy face at work
because they don't want to seem like
they're pouting or seem like they don't
appreciate the opportunity to have a job
and so people suck it up a lot but I
think it's it's important for everyone
to be very honest about their own mental
health with their boss no some bosses
may not want to hear it like I you know
there are people out there who don't
want to hear that but hopefully you can
you can you know explain to somebody
like I'm just feeling burned out like I
need a little bit of extra time or I
need to go home a little bit earlier I
just need I need some space here to fix
some things because otherwise I'm just
gonna put on a happy face and not do
great work and it's gonna end poorly
yeah so you know can I can I have a
little bit more time I need a few more
personal days can I do something and
we've been very careful about this at
base camp although we weren't in the
past but we had a situation once where
one of our employees who'd been with us
for a while had some issues and and he
was trying to kind of fight through them
and it was pretty obvious that he needed
a break and we didn't have any way to
give him a break because we didn't have
any we could give him a day or two but
we didn't have any like institutional
breaks really so we you know this is not
our invention but we came up with the
idea the sabbatical at work which of
course like in academia they haven't
went and some jobs they have it and so
now at Basecamp every three years
everybody gets a paid 30-day sabbatical
just to give people a shot at like just
get some real time off without any worry
and then we also have a lot of people to
take personal days more personally than
that sort of thing but these are things
we've eased into over the years we
haven't always been that way cuz we
didn't recognize you know we didn't even
understand that somebody could have
those those concerns
but people do everyone does and I think
it's important for the boss the owner
whoever to recognize that human beings
are human beings I don't care how cool
the job is I don't care how special it
is I don't care how friendly you think
you are people need some mental health
time in order to like you know tighten
some things out for themselves and you
need to need to be able to give people
that time and also protect people's time
through the during the day so in
eight-hour day is enough but that's
another part of this is that work can
push people to burnout obviously and
it's not always obvious because people
burnout at different rates in different
times so you might think this is fine I
can work 10-hour days no big deal right
but other people may not be able to do
that and you need to recognize that as
well yeah you know Amanda last thing I'm
gonna tell you is our friend Dave Ramsey
he I just I just heard him recently
talking about he was talking to an
attorney who was working 80 hours a week
excuse me and um the he was totally
burned out and you know if he works
really hard for the next decade or
decade and a half he might become one of
the 47 partners in their law firm and
then by the way the work doesn't go away
once you get the next promotion you
climb the ladder now you're setting the
new precedent you have to work even more
that that work that always happened to
me every time I got a promotion
throughout my 12 years at the telecom
company that Ryan and I were at it's not
like oh now it's a relief it's like oh
it's awesome I got this promotion now I
get the privilege of working more and I
it becomes this never-ending cycle where
there isn't relief around the Binion
there is not a finish line that you're
working toward and in fact the closer I
got to the people I aspired to be the
more I realized they were kind of
miserable where I was and if I worked
for the next 20 years then I would
probably be just as miserable as them
because why follow the recipe I'm gonna
bake the same cake there's a path and
once you're on that path and on those
rails you're going where they're going
that's what happens you know it's it's
one of those tricky things because it's
hard it's really hard to just admit that
you need a break or that you need to do
something else the thing is is that we
all create habits like habits aren't
something you set out to
you just create them anyway and the
trick here are not the trick the problem
I guess is that if you work long hours
if you have bad habits or you form bad
habits like it's gonna be harder and
harder to break those habits you simply
just get used to the things that you do
over and over and over and over and you
end up putting up with things and making
excuses for things because that's just
the way it is now like that's just I'm
used to it now now I'm gonna begin to
defend my lifestyle because like I'm so
invested in it so I think it's really
important for people to spot those
things early and and and correct because
kind of what you just alluded to is
really true which is it never gets
easier I don't think it ever gets easier
unless you break like I don't mean like
well sometimes breaking down is kind of
the first step but but but you have to
break those habits because they're not
going to naturally go away and this is
something I think it's important for
entrepreneurs too sometimes people think
they can work long long long hours for
many many years because then eventually
down the road they won't have to but
doesn't work that way people tend to
just keep doing what they've been doing
in the past and it gets worse and worse
and worse and worse and worse and they
dig in and then they think the only way
to get anywhere is how they've already
gotten somewhere which is putting in
ridiculous hours so you gotta break
those habits early and set yourself up
for recognizing that forty hours I would
say is enough eight-hour days is plenty
and and practice that because whatever
you practice you're gonna keep getting
better at and unfortunately you can get
better at working 80-hour weeks and
defending it yeah but one thing I
thought about too is I saw him on your
TED Talks is meetings and how much of a
waste of time those are hard and I was
just thinking maybe she can find things
in her week that she could cut out I
mean you know instead of you know 10
meetings week maybe it's five meetings a
week but yeah I know that that is a huge
time-suck so maybe maybe that's just one
little thing she could do to cut some
time out one other thing I want to add
too it's important to recognize what
control you have over the situation so
of course that was a short voicemail we
don't have all the context about what
she does and how whatever but you can
bang your head against the wall trying
to make changes that you can't change so
if if she's lowering organization she
may not be able to affect the topic on
the organization if it's higher she'll
have more power over the organization we
don't know where she is
but figuring out what she can affect is
is the first step because you can get
really frustrated trying to change
things that you simply just don't have
the leverage to change right now so I
think that's a really important point
too yeah and and also one thing that
adds to your freedom here is if you were
debt free in your personal life because
that does allow you to walk away from a
job that maybe is making you compromise
your values your interest your desires
at this point however if you are in debt
then in fact this is you and I agree
violently on not having plans SEO Ryan I
don't have a ten year business plan
right I don't I don't know what we're
gonna do it would be disingenuous for me
to say yes five years from now we're
gonna have X number of Instagram
followers as though that's even the
point like yeah in fact one thing that's
fascinating Jess who handles all of our
social media she's amazing
she's done freelance work for other
companies as well and they always you
know it's always like well we need to
have X number of Instagram followers by
the end of this quarter and like I've
never gone to her once and Ryan has
never gone to her at all and been like
well we really need to ramp up our
Facebook strategy what are you doing to
get new followers because that's not
that's not the point adding value is the
point and these are just different
channels through which we try to add
value and and I bring all that back to
say that if you are working somewhere
where you are compromising your values
you may have to stay there for a short
period of time and so you're able to pay
off your debt however if you're
debt-free you can leave that place you
can always find a job elsewhere
somewhere else that does align with the
person you want to become and of course
don't expect perfection but there might
be a more ideal place for you to go one
other thing I want to add too is remote
work is a reality so our most of our
company works remotely 56 people about
40 of them live so we're based in
Chicago we have 14 people in Chicago and
then the rest live in about 30 other
cities around the world 35 cities and
remote work is important because it
gives someone an opportunity to work
somewhere else where the cost
living is lower so you know we have one
of our best customer service reps lives
on a farm in Tennessee you know he
couldn't get this job if he had to look
in his you know ten mile radius there
wouldn't be a job you know but he gets
to go live in the family farm I think
it's like a fifth-generation family farm
and do this job because we allow remote
work so that's another option is to keep
your costs down by going to another I
mean Nashville's doesn't have a very
high cost of living which is good but
you know figuring out the cost out of
the equation is important too sometimes
we're always looking to to make more but
if you reduce the the base that you have
to cover you don't have to make as much
and I think people just don't talk about
costs enough you talk about the revenue
enough or you know in this case the
salary enough we're making more but
maybe you just don't need to make as
much that's another way to figure out
how to get out of this yeah vicious
cycle totally I mean the the fastest way
to get a raise is to just spend less
money find ways to spend less money for
sure and I'll say one thing to you know
Josh and I we didn't just quit our jobs
and become minimalists I mean that's
ended start a blog I mean that is that
is like the you know people mistake like
oh you can't just quit your job you be a
minimalist it's like you're right you
can't you have to have a plan so you
know Josh and I for a year at least we
were paying off debt we were spending
less money we were preparing Josh he
laid himself off when he was given the
task to save money he put his first name
his name was 42 people my name was the
first in the list in fact that's what I
was gonna say about the plan thing Ryan
I don't have plans but the one time
where I do find it to be beneficial to
have a plan is if you are in a crater so
to speak so if you're in debt yeah I'm
gonna plan to get out that if you if
there's some sort of a emergency you can
plan for certain things you can't plan
for everything and and I think it's
important to differentiate that we're
trying
well here's my you know Toyota has a
hundred year plan which is funny and
aspirational I suppose and maybe that
helps them with their Six Sigma
processes and all these other things but
we kind of make it up as we go and I
think it's gone way better for us as a
result but only because we had plans to
get us out of it
and once you're out of the crater you
can travel in whatever direction you
want and what that plan does is it gives
you something to look on the horizon for
so you know I would encourage her to you
know set an end date maybe it's a year
from now and what is it gonna take for
her to find different work or to work
less over the next year that is like
huge leverage but if you're going in
every day and you're just reminded of
how you want to leave with no plan it's
it's a recipe for disaster well man I'm
gonna send you a copy of it doesn't have
to be crazy at work I really hope you
enjoy it I think you'll find a lot of
value in that I'm also gonna send you a
copy of our book minimalism live a
meaningful life we identify the five
values that Ryan and I often talk about
the foundational values and I think
getting really clear on what your values
are is going to be really important for
you to move forward to find a company or
a job or a position or maybe even
starting your own business that aligns
with the person you want to be so if you
like our podcast you like the audiobook
version of minimalism live a meaningful
life or we'll send you the book book or
the ebook version of that Ryan I'm gonna
skip Olivia's question for the sake of
time we'll move that for the maximal but
let's move on to you know what time it
is it's time for our lightning round
this is where we answer questions from
social media Jason here's what we do so
we're at the minimalists on Facebook and
and Twitter and Instagram you're at
Jason freedom on the relevant platforms
only Twitter look at that you animal of
it that's my favorite platform is it
yeah so thankfully we have Jess to help
manage get our message out on all those
other platforms but Twitter is also my
personal favorite who's our first
question from Ryan our first question is
from adit yeah if you are a senior
manager at a company that can be crazy
sometimes like many other tech startups
what can you do
to change the culture you know this is a
fascinating question because there are
often people who would like to in some
way influence the culture of their
company but they're new or they feel
like they're so low down on the totem
pole now what we try to do is we answer
these questions in a short shareable
less than 140 character response but not
really
we just we ramp a lot of it
and then Shawn makes something pretty
for the shownotes is something tweetable
out so Jason tell me about how do people
in your company especially you have an
additional layer they're working
remotely how do they influence the
culture especially if they're low down
on the totem pole well this comes back a
little bit to something I said earlier
which is figuring out what you actually
have control over so if you're really
low on the totem pole I mean the very
least we all have control over ourselves
it's to some degree so if we don't like
being interrupted by others all the time
we shouldn't interrupt other people you
know kind of be the change you wish to
see in the world essentially and so I
think you know you got to figure out
where you're at if you're a little bit
of a few have a team lead and you have
three people below you or something like
that or working with you then you can
change that if you are a manager that
manages multiple teams and you can
change that but trying to change the
whole company I think it's just it's not
the right first step it's it's you know
figure out what you can control work on
yourself first make some small steps and
at some point what ends up happening is
that if you let's say you have a team of
three that you're that you're in charge
of and the rest of the company is crazy
and you figure out some calm and all of
a sudden you're doing things a little
bit differently everyone's like and it's
working people what's going on over
there you get some leverage to get back
to leverage everyone's got to figure out
what their lever is and how long it is
and how strong is like how much leverage
do you have and you can build it buy it
with small little victories and then you
know people will look at you and go
what's going on over there
oh he you know he or she lets people
work at home one day a week Oh
interesting maybe we could do that
elsewhere then you can have influence on
the company by doing something in a
small scale other people will pay
attention to it and let them then have
the idea make it there it's it's your
idea like I don't care I don't need to
take credit for the idea like if you
want to steal it for me in you know
apply this company-wide please do that'd
be great so I think that's the way to go
about this you know Ryan when we worked
at the the telecom company there are
thousands of employees there I think
what we don't realize is there isn't
necessarily a company culture there are
many cultures within the company we
worked in the retail side of things and
then for a different period of time Ryan
worked in the b2b side of things and in
the marketing side of things and there
were individual cultures in each of
those places that by the way are
appreciably different when you move from
it's essentially like moving to a whole
new company sometimes right oh yeah man
I I remember Josh is he
a bunch of retail stores and his stores
were like pristine man like you could
literally wipe the top of the case
there's no dust but then you go to like
you know his coworkers retail stores and
there's like clutter everywhere it's you
know dirty in the backroom I mean yeah
it's you do have a little a little bit
of a different environment store to
store it's no different than in a city
so you've got a city which has a general
kind of a cultural angle and you've got
neighborhoods in the city and you've got
blocks in the city and one block might
be different the next block and coffee
shops over here different coffee shops
over here and restaurants over here you
know everything it is a bunch of Mike
this whole idea of a culture is as this
as this one thing it's it's not true and
it's not helpful right it's think about
it in terms of little micro societies
within the bigger society and that's
what you can really have control over
yeah and you can influence other ones
then yeah here's my answer and it's just
echoing exactly what you said already
had this written down be the calm you
want to see in the workplace yeah it's
great man my pithy answer is this you
needn't be a vessel into which others
pour their stress and anxiety and I
think it's too often that we want to
take on other people stresses and
anxieties but we don't have to do that
we can be the calm that we want to be I
think it's important to empathize like
it's important to like you know uh
respect other people's battles but we
don't have to take those battles on
ourselves yes indeed all right before we
get into our added value segment and our
listener tips today it looks like we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week did we do gentlemen
how do you reduce the chaos at work over
which you have very limited control how
do you balance work that needs to be
done for the company or leadership
versus the work you are passionate about
how do you let go of attachment to
results and just focus on the process
itself we have another question here
this one was really fascinating Ryan I
only get a break when I sleep or when I
have no cell phone service
yikes that's a lot of work so what can I
do to get some time to myself without
feeling rude for ignoring emails and
texts and phone calls also this is a
good question and what areas of Jason's
personal life does he take a minimalist
approach and looks like we got about 14
billion more questions for Jason freed
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusive
on patreon that's right you currently
listen to our weekly minimal episode but
each week ride and I record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
talk about topics we don't usually
discuss in public
Plus patreon is best way for us to fund
this podcast and keep it a hundred
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to The Mentalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you can find all the details and all
the good stuff over the minimalists
dot-com Ryan what else you got for us
well as always I want to encourage our
listeners to read more and get informed
and you can do that with Jason Fried's
book it doesn't have to be crazy at work
I'm holding that up for the camera one
more time check it out it's a great book
and then also Josh I got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out hi Josh and Ryan this is
Sandra from Long Island New York I
wanted to share a quick tip for those
looking to let go of extra bags or
luggage instead of donating them to a
place like goodwill you can donate them
to your local foster care system many
children in foster care carry their
belongings in garbage bags by donating
your extra luggage it allows those
children to feel a bit better we're
moving to a new place oh my name is Eve
and I'm from Berlin Connecticut I just
listened to your simple choices podcast
about eating and I just wanted to kind
of share my personal experience with
healthy eating I was diagnosed with IBS
my freshman year of college and this has
been really a big strain on my health
and my eating habits I've had to
eliminate and a lot of foods in order to
keep me feeling good and feeling well
and one of those changes I made was
actually becoming a vegetarian cold
turkey no pun intended and I just wanted
to share that it can be really difficult
to make a big dietary decision like that
and switch in your life going vegan
gluten-free vegetarian a lot of judgment
comes your way when you tell people that
you're currently going through that
transition or maybe already
so I just wanted to share with the
listeners that it's really great to just
be confident in yourself and trust your
process it can be really hard to be able
to express yourself and live freely and
simply when you're receiving negative
feedback and judgment from others but
I'm here to tell you that there's a lot
of people that have improved their lives
eating healthy and making those
transitions so whether you are thinking
about switching to make a big dietary
change or or someone doesn't know a lot
about it and doesn't have a lot of
support in that definitely all of what
you'd like to do and be able to be
consistent and persistent with how your
eating habits are shaping your life in
order to protect your health alright Joe
thanks again to Jason for joining us
today there are a few ways you could
check him out check out his book it
doesn't have to be crazy at work I'm
half way through it
I am absolutely enjoying it I'm probably
gonna finish it in the next day or two
it's so good whether you work for
someone you are a a boss you aspire to
be a boss you want to start your own
company what a phenomenal ethos and then
he's got self or other place you can
find him he has a podcast definitely
check out his podcast it's called rework
FM so we'll put a link to that in the
show notes and his blog which is called
signal vs. noise and you can find that
at 3 7sv
in dot-com you can check that out you
can also follow him on twitter at Jason
freed we'll have links to all of that in
the show notes and real quick four right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
well sort of going on so I teach a
writing class as you know Ryan you've
taken the writing class yes and I was
great we we just had about a hundred
students graduate recently from the the
latest round we cap it at a hundred
students at a time and so enrollment is
currently closed if you're listening to
this the day this podcast episode comes
out enrollment is closed but if you're
interested when we do open enrollment we
open it up for a hundred students at a
time we will probably do that early this
year in 2020 you
the opportunity to to be a part of that
or if you just want more information
about it just go to how to write better
org and you can sign up for the email
list to be notified also you can get
some free writing tips as well for being
on that email list how to write better
dot or it never be any pressure we're
not gonna try to pressure you into
signing up for a course or anything like
that that's obviously not what we do it
tends to to sell out each time anyway
but it is an opportunity for you to
learn how to improve your writing
whether you want to write your first
book or your next book or you want to
start a blog or you want to improve your
business emails or maybe you're thinking
about writing a short story or a short
story collection I believe a rising tide
lifts all boats and I want to help you
learn how to write better how to write
better torque is the place to go if you
want to write better in the new year if
you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or
send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox you can sign up for
the email list over at the minimalists
comm you also receive our simple Sunday
emails with beautiful writings about
living an intentional life with less and
for our added value this week Ryan this
is a an album we were listening to
recently together we were driving to a
Utah Jazz game it was a Clippers game
but they're flying the Utah Jazz and
Joshua Radin has a phenomenal new album
and my favorite track is the title track
it's called hear right now there's
something about his music this is just
so calming so I'd encourage you all to
to have a listen to that and if you all
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus